mais là ça va
non mais allez vas-y bouge non mais oh
je suis pas de son petit copain
non mais t'es pas mon petit copain mais
tu vas prendre ma maman ta gueule est-ce
qu'on peut mettre un peu plus de son sur
beinheim ce qu'on l'entend pas merci aux
sons s'il pouvait envoyer s'il vous
plaît à un micro voilà un truc on
n'entend pas bien ces insultes ouais
ouais
jérémy tu es toujours là toujours merci
j'ai l'impression que tu avais d'autres
projets et un bon ce soir aux usa comme
ça alors jérémy elle a une minute trente
valérie bénaïm pour essayer de trouver
trois serpent mais en plastique valérie
est ce que vous êtes prête bas d'où nous
venons il y en a plein la vue est fermé
la porte derrière qui est soulevée vous
avez fait juste une tente mais non mais
non du mal à les y battant alla les ist
creusot c'est parti à temps à les y
attend balesi métaux oui on est foutu je
veux jouer pour virer mais vous avez
aimé lui transmettait chrono à l'antenne
s'il vous plaît et fermé la porte
fermez la porte les chéris fermer la
porte de la loge voilà ferme hélas pas
vite mais bouge tes fesses benaïssa
dollar baby
recevez pendant tout un temps porté et
j'en ai rien à [ __ ] son ordi gaziers
d'acheter
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ou est-ce qu'on peut boire elle évite
sais pas c'est quoi ça à la salle y en a
certainement en dessous à lévis en vélo
mais ce qui s'est vraiment sensé pas
maman y'a véronique genest ticket vue
véronique genest bien est ce qu'on croit
savoir si bas c'est la tradition des
camions dont jeunes on a commencé ici
pour être le héros les laisser là
abattant serait maintenant aller vers
les gens
[Applaudissements]
médaille dpj mures 30 secondes devant
tiago n'attendra serpent bordeaux attend
à tomber dans une guerre dans une
pharmacie ou dans sa vie paul 30 vital
et ouvrez ouvrez à laisser aller le
chercher
véronique est la vache à l'as rome est
impressionnant et with war diary des
sports a déjà amené le serpent j'aime il
a mené le serpent jaune vous même en
plateau égale le pc mais je peux pas je
te jure ce n'est pas messi mais attendez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allez
prenez le serpent les y amener long
plateau je vais faire tomber valérie
c'est pour le pc portable avec moi thiam
avec moi ben ali c'est pour jouer en
finale
[Applaudissements]
en effet pour jeanne amis je m'en fous
de jérémy je te rencontrer la cheffe
personnes pas le truc la mort à leurs
âmes et l'oseille
non non valérie un vrai serpent à perdre
et serpents plateau mais je peux pas il
est fou ce type
mais si aller sinon c'est perdu pour
jérémy attentes en bas les pros de
l'autre la régal ta gueule bon et teddy
la lumière
[Applaudissements]
je crois qu est-ce que ta gueule
qu'est ce que la la on dirait que c'est
un faux [ __ ] je vois rien bordel allez
ça va aller mais tu nous entends valérie
rabassa passé pour jovial que tu dis je
m'en fout ta gueule d'un émirat nasa pas
vrai pour jérémy ramènerait c'est quoi
tu as là c'est bon je rêvais ça pour qui
c'est vrai ou c'est faux cette merde
ban a baissé pour qu'il vous d'aller
ramer pour qui vous allez jérémy sokona
c'est bon les seuls à la barre la
première fois qu'elle est naturelle à la
télé